seashells they use their shells the
organisms within there
to keep out pathogens and to filter
stuff out that's exactly what our noses
do
meditation is the biggest gift that i
can give anyone
and i would say more than anything it is
whatever reason for success i've had
major strategy in your health and your
productivity
right now is to want to be happy
build a life not just a business
living i believe
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get the complete
guide to perfect health
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one breathe through your nose
with james nestor one of the things that
i am still perplexed by how important it
seems to be
is breathing through the nose i would
classify
myself as a chronic mouth breather i
catch myself doing it all the time
uh i i want to know why does it matter
so much
and what are the benefits if somebody
were to go to
lengths to train themselves to breathe
almost exclusively through the nose
so if you were to cut my head in half
and
i've done this with a with a cat scan
and gotten a deli slicer view
of my whole head you're gonna see that
the nose here
and the sinus passages take up about the
volume of a billiard ball sometimes even
more than that
so this is an incredibly ornate and
complex organ that looks so much like a
sea shell they call it the nasal
concha so sea shells they use their
shells the organisms within there
to keep out pathogens and to filter
stuff out that's exactly
what our noses do so air doesn't just
shoot in
into our nose into our throat we have to
force it through this gauntlet
of turbinates and mucosa and cilia
and all of these different structures
and while air
is being pressurized and forced through
this labyrinth
it is moistened it's heated
it's filtered it's pressurized
and it's conditioned so that by the time
it enters our lungs we can better absorb
that oxygen
so just breathing equivalent breaths
through the nose
then through the mouth will increase
oxygenation about 20 percent
with each breath so that's caused by a
number of things
also nitric oxide uh i
i'm sure a lot of your listeners know
about nitro this wondrous molecule that
does
uh is implicated with uh with
vasodilation
it helps with gas exchange it's
essential we make six times more
no when we breathe through our nose and
if we hum
we make 15 floor fold more nitric oxide
nitric oxide is also some people may be
interested in knowing this that
what does viagra do it stimulates the
release of nitric oxide in our bodies
creates vasodilation uh you know where
so we can we can do this in our in our
noses as well
rule number two exploit the power of
exercise with robin sharma
right now you're probably an
entrepreneur or maybe a business builder
a creative person of some sort or you're
building a family or you're building an
empire
of spirituality or you're working on
your health whatever it is
you have some mountaintop that you're
chasing and along the way
it is a little bit of a war it could be
a war of self-doubt it could be a war
against temptation
it could be a war against distraction
because
we all have these competing diversions
looking for our attention versus staying
monomially focused on the few
projects or pursuits that'll get us to
where we want to get to
and so i'm going to get right into it
the first part of the deconstruction
about
how warriors battle proof elite health
is exercise we know the power of
movement
and yet so few of us exploit
the power of exercising every day
we know that if we exercise we know it
will allow us to live longer it will
give us more energy
it will boost our willpower it'll
release dopamine
the inspirational neurotransmitter so we
feel stronger
it'll release serotonin so we feel more
relaxed
we know exercise promotes neurogenesis
so you'll have more brain cells
we know it actually accelerates learning
and processing
we know it releases bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor
that john ratey calls miracle grow for
the brain
in his wonderful book spark so why
wouldn't you exercise every single day
and we
not many people love getting up at five
in the morning
and exercising for at least 20 minutes
but think about how you feel after those
20 minutes
you feel phenomenal and it's your
neurochemistry at work
and your neurobiology at work and you
have this
in you it's the way your brain and body
has been constructed
you just got to force yourself to wire
it into a habit
and if you believe me and there's tons
of science that proves it but if you
believe me that exercise is a total game
changer
and i recommend to you do it first thing
in the morning because the rest of your
day
in terms of your mindset heart set
health set and soul set
productivity and performance and
happiness is fundamentally different
why would you only do it once a day so
my encouragement with great love and
respect is
do it from five to five twenty and then
at the end of your work day
do a second wind workout this is one of
the rituals that i teach at my live
events like personal mastery academy
where i walk you through all my advanced
protocols on exponential performance
battle proofing your mindset building a
great company living a world-class life
and one of the rituals that i teach at
personal mastery academy
is this protocol it's called the second
wind
workout the second wind workout and so
if you believe that exercise
increases your energy and your focus and
your happiness
and your productivity why would you only
do it once a day
so at the end of your work day you do a
second wind workout it could be a yoga
class it could be a soul cycle class it
could be
walking in nature as i love to do on
most days or going for a mountain bike
ride because
when you exercise in nature it's amazing
what starts to happen you get the fresh
air you get the sunlight
you get the color of the leaves you
reconnect to
your spiritual self you get to breed the
fresh air amazing
so the first point is really warriors
understand
the power of exercise to strengthen
their interior core
and their energy reserves and their
mindset so they win in battle
rule number three realign now with
brendon burchard
major strategy in your health and your
productivity
right now is to re-align
now realign now for
your three-year plan what do you mean by
that
what i would love for you to do is you
know sometimes
when you talk about people's health
they're so focused on right now
they're dealing with that health issue
we talk about productivity they're
focused on
geez i've got all these things i'm
juggling brendan which one
and what i'd love for you to do is
remember high performance also comes
from the element
of strategic thinking and
future casting yourself
like thinking out into the future so
what i love you do is go okay
in three years from today like three
years so
three summers from now i would love for
you to think about
how do you want to look and feel
physically
what do you want to feel like in terms
of your physic
your physiology but your overall health
where would you love to be with your
overall health
in three years what happens is when
we're short-term
focused we fail to set boundaries
when we're short-term focused oh sure
i'll help you with that
oh yeah people-pleasers any any
any people-pleasers out there you're
like oh oh yeah i'll help you oh
i'll do it i'll do it and all of a
sudden you are loaded up
with everybody else's obligations you
are loaded up with
everybody else's needs and desires and
their dreams
and all of a sudden you realize you are
carrying the weight of the world
and not doing your world
you're carrying the weight of everybody
else's obligations and needs
and you're not even living your life and
when i say realign
i mean literally know what you need to
stop
release get rid of and know what you
need to start
but we can't talk about high performance
without talking about the future
and so we must put you future
cast you three years from now minimum
some of you
if you've already done that activity go
five years go a decade
where do you want to be and what you
must you release
right now because when you release it
now two beautiful things happen
one releasing that which you should not
be
carrying is profoundly powerful for your
mental health
all right my friend evan carmichael's
book listen humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
rule number four meditate with ray dalio
meditation is the biggest gift that i
can give anyone
and i would say more than anything it is
whatever reason for success i've had
because it allows one on
back to the two yews i'll clarify
what i mean is that in your mind
there we think what do you want and the
reality is
when you look at the neuroscience and
psychology
that there are different parts of your
brain that want different things
and so in the simplest sense there is
the
logical part of the brain that you're
conscious of it's called the conscious
and you think you're being logical and
you want to make those decisions
and then there's the subliminal below
the limbic system
part of the brain which is the emotional
and it's not as conscious to you but it
has more of an
influence on you than really the logical
one
and so they're not aligned and so when
you're experiencing
that pain or let's say the ego
right there were two main things you got
an ego barrier and a blind spot barrier
if you can get past your ego barrier and
you get past your blind spot barrier
you can accomplish anything because you
also know that you don't have to do
everything to
you have to figure it out yourself you
can take in from other people
the different ways to approach things in
the best possible
way and so the realization that
we all are really struggling with
ourselves
and to think which are which is in
control
meditation helps to deal with the
alignment of those two things rule
number five fix your diet with dr steven
gundry
lectins are plant proteins that are one
of the major defense
systems of a plant against being eaten
one of the things that's hard for us
to con conceptualize is that plants do
not want to be eaten
they actually have a life and they were
actually here first
when insects arrived plants had a
problem because
they couldn't run they couldn't fight
they couldn't hide
but they have a huge advantage and
that's their chemist
they can turn sunlight into matter and
we haven't figured out how to do that
yet
so what they do is they make proteins
that are sometimes called sticky
proteins or lectins
that stick to certain sugar molecules
in us particularly in our gut lining
just by the way if anybody
has sinusitis or runny noses when they
eat certain foods
you are actually producing sugar
molecules in your mucus to trap
lectins and i have so many people who
had chronic sinusitis including myself
when
we finally got lectins out of our diet
they completely went away
so lectins bind to sugar molecules
lectins cause the wall of
our gut to actually separate and people
have heard the term leaky gut
i used if you'd asked me 15 years ago if
i
thought leaky gut was was a problem i
would have said it was pseudoscience
now with the advances in understanding
how the microbiome works and in
understanding how lectins work
i think everyone who has a disease
has a leaky gut now i'm pretty dumb
hippocrates said this 2500 years ago
that all disease begins in the gut so
one of the things we know about research
is research is
research look again because somebody
already knew this
and hippocrates knew it 2500 years ago i
think the first thing you do
is get major lectin containing foods out
of your diet
you won't like me for a couple weeks but
most people
even within a couple weeks begin to
notice a difference now
what are those they're foods that we
actually evolutionary were not designed
to eat
beans are so lethal raw that there's
very good published studies in humans
that they can cause
massive bloody diarrhea and there's some
pretty good studies
in monkeys rhesus monkeys and red velvet
monkeys that they can actually cause
heart disease and even kidney damage
from the lectin content
what's fascinating from a human
evolution standpoint
is that humans up until the dawn of
agriculture
were actually very tall creatures most
humans were about six feet tall
and our brain size was about 15 percent
bigger than it is today
and when if you look chronologically by
8
000 years 2000 years into
grain and bean eating we actually shrunk
about a
foot and our brain size has never
recovered
from 10 000 years ago so
these are anti-nutrients grains and
beans
that's number one number two
two thousand years ago northern european
cows
suffered a genetic mutation a
spontaneous mutation where they stopped
making the normal protein in milk casein
a2
and began making casein a1
now casein a1 has a lectin-like protein
that is converted into a compound called
beta caseomorphing
which can cause a direct immunologic
attack on the beta cell of the pancreas
the
insulin producing cell in the pancreas
and there's some pretty good evidence
and it's accumulating every
every year that one of the causes of
type 1 diabetes or juvenile diabetes
is casein a1 milk and it actually
correlates
very well in countries that have casein
a1 cows
they have much higher incidence of type
one diabetes
than countries that have caseinated two
cows
cheeses for instance are safe from
france italy and switzerland
sheep goats and water buffalo are all
casein a2
and what is it about that that's so
problematic it actually makes a
it's a lectin-like compound that
stimulates an immune response
so just as i would get from the beans or
whatever
exactly you'll get the same thing okay
so it's a it's a very new addition to
our diet
now the newest addition to our diet
is some of our most precious
foods are american north american or
south american
foods for instance in the nightshade
family potatoes
eggplant peppers tomatoes and goji
berries
so the nightshades the peel and the
and the seeds have the lectins and
native american indians
in the southwest always peel and de-seed
their peppers they char their peppers
they de-seed them
and then they either grind it into chili
or eat them that way but they always do
that
the italians always
peel and de-seed their tomatoes before
they make sauce
and is this like a cultural intuition
kind of thing were they
why do i what i like to do is i go
around the world studying cultures and
figuring out
why did they do this how did they
detoxify lectins
for instance rice was invented
8 000 years ago 4 billion people
use rice as their staple yet four
billion people
take the hall off of rice and eat it
white and
surely there can't be four billion dumb
people
who don't know any better that white
rice is bad for them and brown rice is
good for them
in fact they've been taking the hall off
of
rice for 8 000 years same way
believe it or not up until william
and william and harvey kellogg in the
early 1900s
did the idea that whole grains were good
for us
and if you look back 50 years
and when the whole grain goodness really
caught on
you'll notice that a lot of our current
health issues including this
epidemic of autoimmune disease didn't
occur
this epidemic of dementia didn't occur
and so whole grains are one of those
wonderful myths that got perpetrated by
a few individuals
rule number six take cold showers with
jim quick
today's challenge is to take a cold
shower and you're like
i was loving this guy until he said cold
shower
i hate cold showers now why let me talk
about why
because i don't like cold period
i don't like cold baths cold showers
cold environments
but cold could be your teacher many of
you listen
to great avail to uh with great response
to our episode with wim hof i met wim
over six years ago wim hof is the ice
man if you haven't listened to that
episode
please where he talks about cold is my
teacher where he climbs the
himalayas in his underwear and he swam
underneath the arctic
amazing amazing man but he talks about
the power of cold
and if you listen to also my episode on
my morning routine you know one of the
things i do every morning
is i take a cold shower or an ice bath
here so there are a number of reasons
why you want to take a cold shower
and starting with number one it lowers
inflammation
it lowers inflammation so one of the
challenges
to your brain which also is part of your
body
are high inflammation levels and if you
listen to our morning routine we do
things like have
turmeric turmeric tea and such which
sounds really good right after you take
a cold shower
by the way cold reduces inflammation
it's like you
you bang your knee on a coffee table
what do you do you put ice on it to
reduce swelling inflammation
but we also have inflammation in our
body so cold is very powerful with that
again
listen to the episode we did with wim
hof the ice man he's an
expert at that because he lives his talk
he actually does it
the second reason why you want to take a
cold shower in the morning i don't go
through specifics on how long
and such the second reason is because
it's like a
nervous system reset for me it's better
than coffee
when i go into the cold i feel like
after when i come out of it it's like
i'm
brand new and you can attest to this
have you ever gone into a cold lake
before
or just like when you go out in the cold
you come in and you're like you feel
refreshed
it helps to reset your nervous system
the third reason why you do it though
is because you want to get yourself to
do difficult things especially as part
of your morning routine
you get yourself to do difficult things
and that's what's important here
part of the reason we're doing this
quick brain challenge is we know that
challenge leads to real
change when you challenge yourself
through struggle your struggle
by overcoming that struggle becomes a
strength or
if you will a superpower and so what are
you doing you're testing your ability
to be able to deal with what's
uncomfortable and as we talk about if
you're just
doing the easy things put things off
procrastinate
then life is difficult if you do the
easy things life becomes difficult
but if you do the difficult things you
get yourself to do difficult things you
build your grit
muscles if you will then it's going to
show up in a life that becomes easier
you know what i mean like when you're
doing difficult things you have that
difficult conversation with somebody
you get yourself to work out you get all
the benefits of having an easier life
because life is is not necessarily
easier it's just you are better
and so when you're putting yourself in
uncomfortable situations like a cold
shower a cold bath
some of you do a cryotherapy where
you're in a what is it negative
230 degrees for two and a half minutes
obviously consult with your healthcare
practitioner you're putting yourself in
in a safe way in an uncomfortable
situation so you're building that
ability that fitness if you will to be
able to show up and
speak in public if you have a fear of
public speaking or to have that meeting
or
to ask for that sale if you're an
entrepreneur or to do the thing as a
parent that you need to do that you've
been putting off
so again you're building your grit so
again reasons why you want to take all
shower
number one lowers inflammation number
two it's like a big nervous system
reset which is great for your brain and
the third reason
you're training yourself first thing in
the morning to do difficult things
so there's a science to momentum you get
yourself to do difficult things
and then when you get to work doing that
difficult thing that you've been putting
off
because i do believe that the treasure
you seek
is found it's hidden in the tasks you
are avoiding
so as you're getting yourself in the
habit of creating new habits
because that's what we're doing with
this challenge you're going to do it
today or tomorrow the next time you take
a shower now what specifically are you
doing
you want to build your way up to it i'm
not saying take a two minute cold
shower because it's cold it's
uncomfortable so
baby steps right every pro was once an
amateur
and so every every every expert was once
a beginner so you go in and you just do
10
seconds maybe you do 10 seconds on 10
seconds off and also their health
benefits going from cold to hot
if you've gone to some of the spas they
have a cold plunge and then like a
heated jacuzzi so it increases your
vascularity
and so it's building that pump if you
will so go maybe 10 seconds cold
10 seconds hot warmer 10 seconds cold 10
seconds hot and you can build yourself
i do my box breathing my alpha breathing
my fire breathing my wim hof
breathing and i push myself in a healthy
safe way
rule number seven activate your systems
with wim hof
if someone is feeling
sick right now and maybe they have
coronavirus maybe they just have the flu
or some type of cold or something else
maybe they're causing sickness because
of the mind and how they're stressing so
much
who knows why what would you say people
should do obviously if they're
if they're sick they should probably
stay quarantined with this practice but
what should they do
in terms of just feeling better to try
to strengthen the immune system
and weaken the sickness what is
something they could do every day
is it 20 minutes a day of breathing like
you said and ice
and doing the ice stuff even if they
feel weak will that help
is it more breathing what's the strategy
to
increase the immune system if they feel
weak then they should do the breathing
exercises
the breathing exercises changes the
chemistry
brings down the inflammation and when it
is brought down through the breathing
techniques
not hey just do a little bit of
breathing yeah i breathe already
all day long no not that way
just follow the protocol which these
guys in the university
also did also those people are humans
so you are human follow the protocol
and then it will show you will bring
down
inflammation which was weakening the
person
so the person feels weak he brings down
through the breathing techniques
the inflammation then he feels strong
again
he feels connection again and that is
feeling
strong and from there he starts to fight
off the
the sickness yes the inflammation goes
down
with that the sickness and with that he
feels
he has control over
within his immune system at will
again gives confidence and great feeling
that that is one and then from there
then take a a a hot shower take a cold
one
afterwards from 30 seconds to two
minutes
and you're gonna feel even greater
because you
are exercising and activating the
transportation
system of your body and it's all logic
why does breathing help boost the immune
system
by itself why is air into your body and
your cells why does that help
yes when we do these breathing exercises
we have shown in the university
they work different than any other
breathing technique
i have been looking up and
i've gone through science to show it
so that it's factual it's factual
this breathing techniques i've been
exercising
randomly by going into cold water and
cold water is a real stress
and when real stress comes and you are
able by
certain kinds of ways of breathing
then those are breathing techniques
that is able to fend off the stress
of the cold and so that
those breathing techniques after being
so much in the cold
i took home i began to do those same
breathing uh techniques which i was
doing
before but uh to fend off the cold i
i took them home and began to exercise
at home and then it showed wow
this goes deep it it changes my
consciousness
it changes my feeling deeply i see all
the lights
i see all the chakras i see the
enlightenment i see
anything i learned that by going
into a cold water and cold water
is merciless but righteous is what i
always say
but it is so it is my teacher if it
works in cold water
it will work against virus
and or any bacteria i love that and
and more so you learn if you learn how
to deal with cold water
which is very stressful which goes
directly into your
emotion you learn also to deal
with your emotion with your mood
and this has now been shown in the in
the brain scans
that i'm able to connect with the areas
where
emotion is a residing where uh
while stress is coming upon my body i
was able to feel
euphoria and you could not miss because
you could see the brain
and within the brain you know where is
the area of emotion
and where's the area of pain and
sensation and they saw it all and that
was for the first time
all learned in the cold water
then i took that breathing those
those became techniques i took them home
began to do them and it's
amazing what i also and then i went to
the university
and they gave me an injection i began to
do these breathing techniques
and the bacteria had no chance rule
number eight
get rid of stress with dr joe dispenza
70 of the time people live in stress and
living in stress is living in survival
now
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know
a deer gets chased by a pack of coyotes
when it outruns the coyotes
it goes back to grazing and the event is
over and the definition of stress is
when your brain and body are knocked out
of balance out of homeostasis
the stress response is what the body
innately does to return itself back to
order
so you're driving down the road someone
cuts you off you jam on the brakes you
may
you give them the finger and then you
settle back down and the event is over
and boom
now everything's back back to normal but
what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you
outside the cave but what if it's your
co-worker
sitting right next to you and all day
long
you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons
when you turn on the stress response and
you can't turn it off
now you're headed for a disease because
no organism in nature can live in
emergency mode for that
extended period of time it's a
scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes and create disease
long-term effects
human beings because of the size of the
neocortex we can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone we can
think about our problems and turn on
those chemicals
that means then our thoughts
could make us sick so if it's possible
that our thoughts could make us sick is
it possible then our thoughts could make
us well
the answer is absolutely yes so then
what are the emotions that are connected
to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility hatred
competition fear anxiety worry
pain suffering guilt shame unworthiness
envy jealousy those are all created by
the hormones of stress and
and psychology calls them normal human
states of consciousness
i call those altered states of
consciousness
so then we tend to remember those
traumatic events more because
in survival you better be ready if it
happens again that's
and and the survival gene is switched on
you could have 10 really great things
that happen to you in your day
and you just have one bad thing that
happens and you cannot
take your attention off that bad that
that unhappy thing because
the survival gene is switched on rule
number nine start respecting life with
john assaraf
people have to make a decision what they
want to trade their life for
yes because every day we're trading our
life
for the people that we associate with
for
the business or job that we have you
know for what we eat for the health for
the enjoyment for the fun for the
experiences
and you have to ask yourself is my life
worth trading for that
if it's not today is a good day to stop
i know that right yeah but most people
don't think that they're trading their
life
you know for something they think that
you know oh there's tomorrow and there's
next week really
well i have you know evidence to prove
otherwise
that we have no idea you know when the
last breath will be
yeah so let's trade our life every day
as it's the most
important thing in the world and not
from an ego perspective
from uh from a humble grateful
perspective of wow i get
another day to live and to to enjoy be
grateful
to be grateful for that but then to
respect it
see respecting your life means you're
going to trade it
for things that you feel are worthy
of it most people you know ask
themselves the wrong question
they ask themselves you know am i worthy
of the goal and the dream that i have
and they should be asking themselves is
that goal that dream that i have
worthy of my life
change the question and if you say yeah
i'll trade my life for that good then go
and do that
and rule number 10 the last on before
very special bonus clip
is live authentically with gabor mate
let me tell you about a friend of mine
who
lives in calgary her name is shannon
duke
and shannon is 48 years old now and when
she was 37
she was diagnosed with stage 4 breast
cancer
stage 4 meant that the cancer was
already in her bones by the time it was
diagnosed
at that time she had two young children
age one and three and married to a
well-to-do businessman she herself
was a very high functioning executive
for microsoft in calgary
and then she's diagnosed she had the
perfect life perfect marriage perfect
home of course
and then she's diagnosed and healthy
physically you know fit
always ate well and then she's diagnosed
with stage 4 breast cancer
and
she has a transformation
now she gets the best medical advice she
can get anywhere in north america and
she traveled to new york and elsewhere
she got the best medical treatment and
with that she was given one year to live
because that's the prognosis stage four
despite the medical treatment chances
are you'll be dead in one year
now a year ago in february just a year
ago now
shannon traveled to the napa valley of
california with some of her friends
and they celebrated her 10th year
survival and her
47th birthday and the transformation
that she experienced was
that when she was diagnosed and started
paying attention she realized that her
life had not been her life
because she was sexually abused as a
child
and her response to the abuse was
of course as many children will
experience
it can't be about the adults it's about
me so if i would if this terrible thing
happened to me i must be a very bad
person
so i have to be very good to compensate
so the good daughter who doesn't talk
about it doesn't disturb the waters
the good employee the good student the
good wife who doesn't talk about the
husband's addiction issues because that
would again disturb the waters
and when she's diagnosed and she decides
she wants to live she says the hell with
all this perfection and goodness
and she confronts her family a virgin
about the abuse that she had endured and
she confronts her husband
and she starts leaving an authentic and
she leaves the job by the way which
wasn't her
wasn't really expressing who she was now
11 years later the cancer is still in
her bones but it's completely inactive
but she knows that if she wants to stay
alive she needs to stay authentic
so that i believe that
many of these issues are reversible like
i'm not promising a cure here to anybody
but shannon really underwent
a major self-journey and she continues
every day to work at it and she
she practices her spiritual ways which
she ignored all those years
and she pays attention to herself and
she keeps clearing the stuff
out and she is the picture of health
her and i give workshops together
sometime
so that there's ways to get there but
it's a commitment
and of course it might threaten the
attachment relationships
so that's always your call now i've got
a special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an
action plan for what you're going to do
you increase it from 35
to 91 chance of you actually following
through and
when you share your plan publicly that
jumps to 95
chance of following through so i want
that for you i want to know your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so i
can celebrate
you i usually go to sleep around
midnight uh and i usually wake up around
7 30 7 7 30 somewhere in there
um that's a typical day it gets thrown
around every now and then but that's
that's kind of typical for me
okay so as an entrepreneur right with
like a crazy schedule because i know
you're
such a schedule like you have your set
days on when you produce episodes when
you
do your you know public appearances
right like with you know blab
and just go on other people's podcast
it's like how do you manage all that and
how do you manage to really get enough
sleep with all that crazy schedule
yeah and i have an added thing where i
have a really weak immune immune system
like if i don't sleep
seven hours consistently at least i get
sick
if i go two days in a row of bad sleep
i'm sick
uh i'm just it's you got a phone call
there bro yeah
it's supposed to be a mute uh yeah i get
sick like and for people who've been
watching my channel
uh there's a lot of videos where i'm
sick and
um it's often because of like either
lack of sleep or just
you know at the dance studio there's
always lots of people and you know
you catch viruses um
so i need sleep if i if if i don't get
sleep one night the next night has to be
solid or i know i'm gonna be up
so how do you ensure that you get that
you get your seven hours then
yeah so a couple couple things i think
some of them are basics that you
probably heard before
you know try to keep to the same time uh
try not to eat like a heavy meal before
going to sleep because
at least that keeps me up uh i'm super
sensitive to light
so i i have a mask on that that you know
like if i travel i forget my mask i'm
having terrible sleep
um but some other things that may be a
little different than what most people
are doing
um one we have no electronics in the
bedroom
so there's no cell phone or bedroom
there's no ipad in the bedroom there's
there's nothing with a light you know
like if people stay up and read that
like blue screen and that just keeps you
awake
and so our phones are plugged in uh
outside the room and so my wife has an
alarm in the morning she's gonna get up
out of bed to go turn it off there's
nothing electronic
in the room um so that one helps because
before we're
kind of sitting in bed next to each
other before we pass out
and i think one it also kind of gives
you a little more connection because
there's
there's nothing to read so you talk to
yourself okay
talking to your wife before going to bed
but i think you know you get so
distracted by emails and news and stuff
so
so no electronics in the room and that's
that's helped both of us i think
sleep um two is
when i get an idea i go and take care of
it
uh so i'll get out of bed sometimes you
go to bed with with an idea like oh
you know i got a great idea for julian's
dance studio man and then
and then you lie in bed trying to forget
it and and you know wrestling with it
and for me it'll keep me up all night
and
uh and then i'm gonna worry that i'm
gonna forget it because i don't have a
great memory if i don't write it down
it's gone
and so i will get up and send that email
off
to julian to tell him about what he
needs to do for his dane studio
uh or whoever it is and then it's like
it's released because otherwise it stays
with me and i have a terrible sleep and
so i'm not afraid to get up and out to
solve whatever is kind of that that
monkey in my head i need to
release it um having a routine
to help you wind down i find super
helpful
so just like you know when you're a kid
you have
you have a routine that your parents
give you right like you have a bath and
you brush your teeth and you get a
bedtime story and like
you get used to that yeah uh routine and
then that helps
you like oh your body starts to shut
down right
uh and then we kind of lose a lot of
that when we get
into adulthood and it's it's i used to
find it really hard like i come back
from
my salsa studio after a great night
and i'd be wired like talking to people
and like i just can't go
to sleep right away and so i need to
create a schedule a little routine to uh
to decompress a little bit
uh and so whatever it is for you it's
great for me uh we start by i light a
candle
so we have a candle since we don't have
electronics in the room we also turn up
the lights so light a candle
um that's on my wife's side and that's
how i start you know i'll then open up
the bed and like
make space for both of us and then go
and like brush my teeth and
just read some news to like decompress
get my mind off business
um you know floss wash my face
go to bed do some cuddling and then go
to sleep and so it's like the same
thing every night and then as soon as i
go to the bedroom to turn on the candles
i start weighing down decompressing
winding down
and then i start getting tired and after
like the 15-20 minutes of taking to
everything else then
i'm ready to go to sleep um so having
that kind of routine whatever it is for
you
i find helps
[Music]
if you want to know how to never get
sick again with wim hof check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there to me god is cold
you could say that i think of the gold
as a noble force
it's just helping me it's training me